welcome to this video round hmm to round
two coverage of Zurich chest challenge
and um yeah let's have a look this round
cause three games just three games it
feels like little after toddler see
where we always had six games to to
watch but i must say that especially
today i'm glad that it's only three
games because i'm recording this at 1am
my time after I've worked about 10 hours
almost 11 hours rebuilding my home
office yeah I'm got new furniture and
wreak abled everything and so on like it
feels like 10 10 hours of really tough
work that strange afterwards that you
think 10 10 hours what on earth did it
take 10 hours yet but it was some much
work to do but I'm glad that I'm
finished so now i'm doing this video and
i'm pretty much done so you should take
everything i say with a grain of salt ii
and this time okay let's have a look we
have Gelfand koala is the first game and
koalas so surprisingly playing d
six-year very fighting move girl phantom
does not accept the invitation to play
you form i'm not sure what kawana would
have played here the fitted or all that
comes how to tell it's not both openings
are not regular guests in this practice
d6 however has an additional idea and of
course it is that c4e five is very
satisfactory for black so why players
basically play for Knight f3 and Dell
funders going for 93 that supposed most
popular move among default players
however you have committed yourself a
bit of course with a night under three
and corona again is offering a
transposition to and pick modern defense
but the girl from declines and stays
within the deep porn openings yeah now
karana place f5 and them what you manage
to do here is to get into a Leningrad
touch via somewhat twisted move order
but the the main point of this move what
is that wider has already for faded some
options against the Leningrad systems
with them without c4 for example there
are some lines with c3 there are also
lines with night h3 these are not
possible as well and of course all types
of anti Dutch lines like d4 at five
Bishop g5 the storm gambit whatever all
this is not possible so this is a very
clever move Lauda to enter the Dutch the
only drawback is already on move one
that white can play efore here so a
combination of the modern milk defense
against evil and the Dutch in this move
water is very nice weapon so let's see
at the end we get the normal mainline
physician at this point for years
Queenie eight was the most popular but
in recent times C 6 which is actually
the widow move the classical move has
become somewhat more popular one the
reason being that the classical reply to
that if I have traditionally the main
line nowadays is not considered to be so
dangerous of like due to the simple
setup with e5 and this pawn which looks
a bit sick it's not a real problem like
very often can easily cover it with
Queenie seven and then putting something
on the D file this is in fact a quite
satisfactory position from
and this led to the dialysis prompted
wise to do two other moves sides d5 and
galvin is playing a very rare move
before the general idea before it's not
unusual at all but normally you don't do
it with a light on c3 but play before
even earlier so that you can play Bishop
b2 to to influence in five the issue
with the knight on c3 year is that the
media d5 as possible and corona is doing
that yeah it's a bit of a problem now
the null diagonal gets opened white
exchanged it's not much choice and yeah
here the problem is if if white should
white would take here you have this this
type of problem the long diagonal those
pieces are hanging and here's again two
pieces hanging and ninety-three of this
is not helping g4s just week of weekend
squares and yeah white also must reckon
with them advance efore if you place for
example move like queen bee three you
must be ready for reform and this also
would improve blacks position greatly
the bishop on g7 is just a very strong
Gavin played a form to whom yeah
drastically prevent any e5e phone lines
um this now leads to some trades after
we should be six yeah note that this is
attacked
yeah girlfriend took on me five which is
a bit risky it seems that after the
trade and night ft seven white only has
one one continuation this is one
together phone plate it took and now we
should be too it was necessary to cover
this this c3 night however now after
Knight b6 we see if that c4 is a very
weak square and black will regain the
pawn move like c5 is already losing her
versus just terribly overloaded the
Queen side here yeah what what you did
is the right one rook see one yeah now
if the night takes you can just drop the
bishop back and don't have any
particular problem Bishop takes was
played and Bishop a one yeah we have a
position where white has the slightly
better pawn structure five pawns and
only to pawn islands and black has got
three porn islands with those two split
pawns however if you look at the piece
activity this is strong also strong the
night on b6 they are slightly
questionable but it can be activated off
95 and black get some more active with
this pieces and this should be you
should be balanced however in the game
we see that after some more maneuvers
it's not really I mean you could look at
this in more detail but there is not
much going on the main point is that if
you look at this position it stays the
same just it's yeah the type of position
that say stays the same black has got
the activity for the slightly worse
structure it's got the good night and
the very active rook that is operating
on the default on the fourth rank
and the issue is that after some moves
like that it continues for a while all
this is fairly fairly normal check we am
after a while check yeah black black
avoids the draw with a six and it's not
clear that this is such a great decision
I mean blackest not worse really but the
problem is that after a couple of moves
we see especially after this rook trade
that blacks temporary activity has faded
somewhat and yeah he is slightly worse i
mean it's it's questionable if Y term
really can do something and then in
terms to win the game but the rook trade
really yeah maybe black should have
retreated actually why did why did he
trade exactly it could also just put it
back let's say here for example well
maybe he was afraid of something like
that a 59 to c5 yeah but I think keeping
looks on is easier the night end game
here I don't know white right i think
has something i mean if you look at this
and the king is invading and yeah white
white this is definitely better in this
position but it's not easy to win really
here f4 was also interesting just
immediately attacking the knight and
yeah probably the check here check check
and we get this three against two with
nights hmm
hmm yeah I'm unsure if I tell some does
might have some real winning chances I
don't I don't I don't really think so
with the porn f5 key note of six
blackest stays down can't stay passive
but probably add that this is not
winnable it's just 3a ends too hmm i'm
not i'm not sure i'm not sure and i
would need to look at this much much
deeper to to determine if white can win
in the game it it gets to a similar
position actually in Philadelphia very
very similar 93 and in this next couple
of moose kawama defense very nicely at
this nine in turn came here and here I
g4 here played an interesting move we
played h4 I think this is one want key
motif in defense and a very important
one um after this I think black drawers
relatively comfortable comfortably yeah
one night age 49 h 2 is very easy this
black can never loose can also quickly
attack the pawn & get it I think yeah
and the pond pawn takes was played you
know you went 93 and 92 to f4 is
attacking therefore form and this is
very very difficult to defend and maybe
here the white should have tried to
replate 95 maybe after night here he
should have tried to to keep the F porn
like this this was maybe a bit tougher
but night each form I cannot really
believe that right can can we
this position of course you can try but
it should be it should be a draw in a
game it was I think even a bit simpler
so black got this back you know yeah
it's implies not to not true it's
basically the same you get the council
play now and him at the anterior they
agree to a draw kawana would of course
just take the pawn it at the next move
sacrifice the lie to get rid of the last
poem yeah I don't know I guess that
girlfriend somehow around here he had
something but it's not entirely clear
cap if you if you can win and how you
should win um yeah as mentioned due to
my office building project I had less
time than usual to look at this and I
cannot give you a definite answer if
girlfriend could have could have won
it's it's not unlikely but it's
certainly not a trivial matter I mean of
course I is an engine to to recheck or
what I thought and the engine does not
give any clear conclusion it even gives
debt drawn positions like that as
clearly edge for white at least at first
takes take some seconds to now the Deb
it's it's it's not so easy with with an
engine alone to to get a definite answer
okay let's um hmm hmm yeah let's go on
unter Nakamura are not Nakamura yeah
this she has lost the first game against
aronian so very bad start and to the
sternum do on the camera has some as
plate has played his plate draw right he
drew against him kawana
okay let's see what happens Lucia
playing a fall and la camara
surprisingly not surprisingly he's
played this before it goes for the
Berlin he has some gain some experience
in this end game recently and it did
fairly well with it and of course while
there's some psychological thing going
on of as well island didn't really find
anything against the Berlin in the match
against cars so it's a yeah it's a sort
of probing a weak spot him yeah I played
d3 dumb I really I mean it's the end
game really that debt I not had an
excellent score was with the end game
just the classical burn in worland game
system yeah I know I still feel that he
can do maybe more in this tab position
then after d3 just look what what we get
here d3 Bishop c5 and now he took on c6
this sir he had also tried in the world
championship match with absolutely no
edge in the opening yeah 83 intending to
prevent Bishop g4 but I can just develop
yeah nakamura went for long castles
which is probably a bit risky and I I
read some information about the postgame
press conference when a camera yeah was
a bit critical of this decision because
really wide gets get something on the
queenside well blankets not so quick we
see that check arnaud indeed plays on
the queenside funny confirmation here
yeah his intention is to to push the ape
on trying to open up the file for the
rook or get a dangerous Paul near the
king and we see that this quickly
materialize
six yeah this is protecting the porn may
be preparing g5 this is of course one
idea that was tempting for that camera I
guess to cast long because this she had
already played h3 so g5g for has already
made attack for black it just takes very
long and yeah we see that after f6 there
should be 394 first what is playing a 5
n term yeah this is a bit tricky for
like you need to react here you don't
really want to take a look at this I've
got this idea rook a 7 yeah it's just an
open a file and you cannot really allow
to take so b5 was played and now
officially played deform and I think
really this is a mistake it looks some
looks we're really normal opening up the
center but I think it should play the
should just play a six and and go from
them yeah black probably needs to play
be 6 cm I don't really see a another
move b6 and now maybe even take and play
rook e1 this is the the engine
suggestion Houdini suggestion giving
white a very very substantial advantage
which surprises me a bit on that it
should be so dramatic but yeah white the
IES some troms is a porn is dangerous
like always must watch out for this pawn
and after the coming five fe 95 this is
just a very strong position let's say
king v 8 f just for example this is
probably a good plan anyway if I've
takes Knight eggs yeah this is just a
very strong piece it looks at c-6 looks
at seven now white white has something
here and the the problem with deform
what
one plate is that now like I'm where I
can start a sacrificial attack and yeah
yeah he just he just went for it Knight
takes h3 it's slightly surprising that
this should be working but it does take
stakes and a working means it's leading
to to unclear play black it's not the
straightaway winning but it leads to
very complicated and unclear play and
one thing is I think pretty clear this
is much easier for black to play because
the White King is so yeah it's so under
fire at the moment it's not looking so
dangerous but black has very simple
continuations to get more pieces near
the king um yeah if white yeah let's
look it took yeah but if I could save
the rook for example then there's Bishop
g4 this is a very annoying pin you know
that like an probably easily exploit
later weiter has a hard time to get get
rid of this this configuration so this
is not really good and if white takes
which was played there was 26 the direct
mate threat which means ok there's am a
threat and the queen is saying so you
needed to play 92 this was of course
planned now after this we can really
take stock here Blackham has some how a
concert two pawns right White's got five
blacks got seven years got two pawns and
look for two pieces but the main point
is the king and blacks play is just very
easy you need to activate the rooks and
try to get something against the king
while white needs to combine defensive
moves moves that maybe do something with
the a pawn moves that yeah keep the
center intact this is some
just very difficult in comparison for
white to play in supposed to black let's
just look at this c3 which makes sense
it gains the square i had prepare so
maybe this at some point and black it's
just a yeah okay one safety moves with
the king and now rook d6 with the idea
f5 group g six winning the Queen and
this is just what black is doing he
pushes the pieces towards the king and
it's not easy at all for white to to
defend we see that at first that's not
much happening but rather quickly black
get some gets really near the king now
here the next plan is to launch the H
pawn and whites players is very yeah it
doesn't have a claim well why do you
attack a middle material wise it's not
so terrible but what I really don't
doesn't have a simple plan to follow
well black now is pushing the h-bomb and
especially with limited time it's very
very important to know what your general
ideas and it's not so clear what White's
ideas he would like to trade queens for
example but you cannot force that very
difficult to achieve of course like it's
not trading keeps the Queen's on yeah
and now step by step black is making
progress while white really does not
have any constructive idea it's um it's
very very very difficult position to
play around here and I think white wine
is in big trouble already yeah after age
from of course the night needs to react
and it seems that white only has one
play will moves that just light a fire
and after rookie six however Black is
still for choice it's easier to play and
the white king will not find a safe a
safe spot in the near future what he
played however 92 is directly losing the
other line was just easier for black to
play but not losing immediately this now
loses immediately due to direct attack
ruki 8 attacking the Queen needed to
retreat and after this check this now
black has a winning winning move if you
like you can treat it as a puzzle it's
not it's not super difficult but it's
not a simple to move on so try to find
the the way for black head to improve
the position to decisive proportions
I'll be silent for a couple of seconds
yeah maybe it it was easier than I
thought because one of the somewhat
spectacular moves yes only one really
available yeah and it is the the
exchange like second you three after
takes which I was played of course Queen
takes is not possible just to show that
it's really first mate down takes now
Queen d2 and this is the pin that kills
why'd he protects the night the only
moved to protect it was the queen with
and now Luke f6 the Queen now is
attacked and here already an island
resigned it does not have a good square
simply if it goes to g2 you just take
here and this threat is too much yeah
note that rook f1 it's not saving due to
h3 and why this is totally overloaded
this will win the house
yeah very bad start into this tournament
for Anand who really is in a bad shape
for for for a long while he was he
wasn't really a playing well in the in
the World Championship match and now in
this tournament he started the two
losses so yeah will be very interesting
to see if he somehow can recover for the
candidates tournament but at the moment
it doesn't look like he will fight for
father for a new chance against Carlton
and this and this upcoming candidates
tournament he really needs to
consolidate somehow and play yeah some
some decent games once in a while
because it's not like if you look at the
ratings he still has an excellent rating
it's not like he's playing this level at
the moment he just plays a far below
that because he's steadily losing points
so I'm it's really am it's really a bad
bet Faison as his career all right let's
look at the young the star game of the
round cards on against Aronian world
number one against world number two and
somehow somewhere right this is the
highest-rated single game ever with an
rating average of two 8 40 or something
yeah well let's see what happens cousin
again playing c4 it seems that he has
made this as a main weapon at the moment
and I wrong young it goes for the
reverse Sicilian with f5 it's a line
that he plays sometimes but not so often
and we get this reverse Estonian dragon
note that just for those of you that
don't know the line here too well note
that a very important difference to the
normal
dragon is that we the dragon as a black
opening where you often have those
dramatic long castles and those raised
situations this is really not possible
in in this opening with reversed colors
simply because why it is so quick and
playing d4 for example if black would
try that let's say we should be six
canceled and f6 young to set up this
Queen d7 long castles business now why
plays deform and black is already in
some in some trouble he's threatening to
take threatening me for and yep like
rydia doesn't have a move something like
this already as its disastrous the move
f6 especially is especially useless
after this opening of the center black
really only has one one set up here and
this is what Aronian is playing in place
night back to be six and now Bishop e7
this is a setup that is also possible of
course against the dragon in the
Sicilian they're just called the
classical variation with Bishop e2 and
this type of slow maneuvering approach
against the dragon that's not so bad for
white as well within with an extra
temple but this is a setup for black
against the English that is enjoying a
really solid reputation yeah very neat
set up the bishop is nicely positioned
on f8 guarding the kingside the rook is
fulfilling a useful role here and this
can be especially true if like at some
point place 94 I am 15 it's doing that
soon if whites now will take which is
probably not advisable at this exact
moment
after this note that the rook is a very
useful role on the edge the accountant
didn't take off once he played III and
this is one one move White has subtract
an also move the night away which is
keeping more pieces on the board it's
not necessarily better or sharper but
white can play here on 91 both moves on
a possible it have been have been played
before well III is not so bad it gets
rid of the night immediately this is
some virtue of the smooth but it does
not feel that black has any particular
problem a form of course is an important
which fixes this a three Pawn so that
the f8 Bishop always attacks it I keep
getting this menu and yeah the only real
issue for black here is got two issues
to worry about the b7 poem is of course
under attack this needs to be addressed
and yeah white if possible would like to
play the night to c5 and this is what
like also needs to be the way off of
course this is not so easily if possible
but Quincy to this kind of stuff is the
possible plan and we see that aronian
immediately addresses the b7 issue and
now develops the bishop yeah the rook
looks a bit silly but it fulfills a
useful role here it protects this
important pawn and it's nothing that
cannot be a be corrected this root
position I mean yeah here
95 this is what black he needs to take
care of is it ticking and now putting
the bishop back yeah this is in fact
preventing 95 if no 95 I can take care
and and even win instantly because there
are two pieces saying so 95 is not not
leading to anything but trouble Bishop
g4 yeah this is some slight provocation
I'm f5 film but f5 is not a good move
white just drops back and we'll make
some use of this weekend squares and
cons this is simply good just retreated
and asked why dwell what I into it with
this bishop on g4 it's something that
needs to be corrected soon enough Bishop
f3 back ya hear I'm Aronian played b6
yeah what about f5 here is this a good
move not really maybe you can treat this
as an exercise as well why to play and
get a big advantage yeah the move is 96
neat little trick one point is that
after the bishop takes on a three check
their screen a two and yeah why does
winning with the checkmater check give
all kinds of chemicals and moves but at
the end check checkmate we had we get
this mate so after at 596 black needs to
take here purchases of course an
excellent transformation for why to gain
the bishops and an enormous bishop only
five so black cannot play at five but v6
is a simple and good move it make sure
that nothing ever comes to see
I've c6 is slightly we can spot but I
was white ever going to place a piece
now not going to happen he played Bishop
before and accepted this double porn I
guess still to increase the pressure
here needs to exchange and now 95
becomes an interesting idea this is why
you played Knight f6 Carrodus if black
takes there's 95 or first this and 95
it's not it's not really helpful to take
this is what I wanted to do I want you
to draw the zero so taking us not really
helping just 90 f six is better covering
the critical squares yeah okay this gets
lost but Black gets be fall back yeah
Black is some slightly more active but
with some precise moves there's simply
nothing up an angry yeah rook d3 was a a
way to temporarily gain the spawn check
like us losing this back and now having
two pawns attacked of course this is a
bit of a self pin but there is no way
really to to exploit it if black plays
94 and I think it did that right yeah he
did that sorry I thought you did
something else what you really played 94
yeah now white can can draw easily with
Queen takes d5 understand this happened
now I'm of course Queen takes January
bed so night x and now check winner five
check is a very important motif to
remember this type of Perpetual on f5
and CA this is really happening quite
often
look at this check black it only has g6
to avoid these checks but yeah this is
something that check maybe is playing
for loss here well very certainly
playing for losses black can never ever
win so there is nothing else than check
ingles to accept this perpetual check so
draw between Charles uronian not the
most exciting game but the very it looks
like a very precisely played game by
both sides and then it can very often
end in a end in a draw all right I hope
you enjoyed the coverage it was a bit
briefer than usual but um I hope you
understand that I really hadn't put I
didn't have any time today and what I
really need is some hours of sleep yeah
all right I still will be back tomorrow
with with further coverage and I will
have more time tomorrow to focus on the
analysis thanks for watching bye